It is a highly appreciated model for its
great characteristics because it can
regenerate almost any part of its
body. This currently leads to
the axolotl being in a category of
risk of extinction,
but for us as indigenous people and
peasants that in rural areas
somehow try to  reverse this
great problem
at the beginning of time when
the gods gather around the fire they
had to sacrifice themselves to give way,
for example, to the sun to the moon
in this meeting was the
twin brother that just as god is, they only
begin to sacrifice themselves by throwing themselves  to
fire to give life to one
the element when it is the turn of the god only
he refuses to sacrifice himself in his brother
who is the one who gets annoyed and sends him to
chase him to be sacrificed undergoes
several transformations until he
finally finds the lake of
xochimilco and  in this lake then he takes
the form of an axolotl and
his brother who is as he is
to life is thrown into the water  He condemns it from now
on you will live in Moscow
and you will always know how to stay in that
state like a ball.
The water
has been seen more.
from
pre-Hispanic times, the most
important characteristic of its state of neoteny
is not a characteristic stage, a
larval stage of the axolotl in which it
remains for the rest of its life,
unlike the common salamanders
that we know of, its natural habitat is
already reduced to only a few
channels between years sitting xochimilco and this
leads us to have made
promotions with the biology institute
and initially the uam xochimilco in
1998 where they found in that first
census 6000 axolotls per square
kilometer every four or five years they are being
made  censuses and we have already noticed a
very marked decrease in 2014
we did the last census and we
only have 35 axolotls per square
kilometer in
the beginning.  the problem has not been a
proper release and organisms from
outside the place in this case we are talking
about tilapia or women
the chemical contamination that occurred at the
beginning of the last century due to the
diversion suffered by the
freshwater springs that fed the grains
The canals were diverted to
Mexico City for drinking water purposes and
the canals were filled with
wastewater from the city,
together with the urban sprawl that
is bringing the lake area closer every day if
drastic measures are not taken after
a few  decades is going to disappear
completely from the channels
he civac has developed a program of
maintenance of a colony for
several decades where
we currently have the capacity to
mass produce
thousands of juveniles that we have been
using for repopulation purposes
the axolotl is really is  easy to
reproduce it will not go extinct from
laboratories or zoos
or collections because in a  At
egg laying we can have up to
two thousand new thousand five hundred thousand 700
eggs of course we know that if
we have them confined in a
research center we will never be successful
and what we do is make
a permanent monitoring right
now we are about a year and a half
Approximately after starting this
monitoring, we currently have animals
in there, it is a closed space, it does not
have public access,
so it would also guarantee the
safety of the species, which is
why our concern as
locals is how we are going to preserve it and
this is the great objective,
that is our territory there.  we
live there we develop we coexist with
a whole series of elements and in this
case the axolotl and it is part of our
culture part of
the root is part of our identity